If I already know I have leaky got, do I have to run the Syrex array 2?
So the Syrex array 2 test for anybody knows what that is.
This person knows what it is.
It's for a test to the permeability.
And it's easy to go, well, I already know I have a test to the permeability.
So why do I need to run that test?
Well, the benefit of running that test is that there's several different levels of a test
to the permeability.
So when we talk about leaky got, we talk about damage of what are called the tight junctions.
So your epithelial cells bond together like this.
And when you have inflammation in the gut because of food sensitivities, because of damage,
because of chemicals, food colors, all these different things that damage your gut, the
cause inflammation in your gut, you could have a weakening of that tight junction.
And that separates those cells and you could have things get into your bloodstream through
those cells that never was supposed to get into your bloodstream.
Larger protein breakdowns, larger peptides, that never should across the gut barrier.
So you've got this barrier breakdown.
So things are getting across the gut barrier and now you're creating antibodies against
things.
That's how you develop food sensitivities.
So you have sensitivity to gluten, you have sensitivity to dairy, sensitivity to all these
different things.
Why is that?
Because you have a damaged gut.
So that is typically how leaky gut is explained.
And that's true, but that's actually only level one of gut permeability.
That's called paracelular permeability.
So it's between the cells, paracelular permeability.
There's another level what's called transcellular permeability.
And that is actually the cell itself.
You have cells that are so damaged, things are actually getting through the cell into the
bloodstream.
That's called transcellular permeability.
And Cyrex tests for different enzymes that are going to show that.
And different antibodies that are going to show that.
So you're going to be able to differentiate whether you have paracelular permeability or
transcellular permeability.
And then the last and worst situation is that you have lipopolysaccharide production.
So if you have lipopolysaccharide production because of permeability, that's the worst case
scenario.
If you have lipopolysaccharide production, lipopolysaccharides actually prove it to
in themselves damage the blood brain barriers.
And now you're going to have blood brain barrier damage.
So the worst situation is really paracelular permeability, transcellular permeability, and
lipopolysaccharide production.
So it's just a different, it's, it's, so the Cyrex array too is telling you what is going
on.
It's not telling you why.
It's not telling you, like, you know, it's because of your exposed to this chemical.
Or because you're continuing to eat gluten when you have celiac disease.
Or because you, you know, it's not telling you that, but it's telling you what you have.
So there's certain antibody tests that tell you, you know, they give you basically a diagnosis.
And that would be the Cyrex array too.
So it can be beneficial to know that.
You could, you have to kind of treat the person a little bit differently that way.
If you know they have paracelular damage too.
Same thing with the Cyrex array five.
That's telling you, do I have self-antibody Cyrex array seven X?
Do I have neural self antibodies?
There's some lab core tests that test for different systemic antibodies.
So those are, those are autoimmune tests to get a diagnosis.
So if I run Cyrex array seven X and I have antibodies to myelin, she cells, you know that I have
demyelination taking place every time I have an immune flare.
So I'm, you know, exposed to a trigger where there'd be a food or a chemical and my immune system
is flared.
It's very possible that I'm going to have more demyelination.
This is what causes MS.
This is what causes any demyelination disease and dysfunction that goes along with that.
So to know that you have that can be beneficial.
So there's labs that you'd run to get a diagnosis, but that just solves the problem.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
I have antibodies to myelin, she cells, good as sex, I either have full-blown MS or pre-MS.
And okay.
Well, what do you do about it?
Now you got to figure out your triggers.
So there's other antibody tests that you test for like a chemical antibody test or a pathogen
antibody test.
That's array 11 and array 12 or food antibody tests to dig into what are the triggers that
are causing this damage.
So array 2 is one of those that tell us, you know, the level of damage to the gut that the
Cyrex array 3, 3X, it is now called test for all sorts of different peptides of gluten.
I'm already off of gluten completely, or maybe you could skip that test.
There are four tests for gluten cross-reactants because you may be reacting to something because
it's across-reactant to gluten.
So that's a valuable test to run.
So maybe you could skip the array 3X if you're already completely gluten free and you're
religious about it.
I tend to recommend the 3X for a lot of people because it helps them realize that they have,
they do have antibodies to gluten because many times people say, I can eat gluten and
I don't have any problems.
Well, maybe you don't have any symptoms, but it can be causing other problems.
And then the array 4 is the cross-contaminated, gluten cross-contaminated and then a larger
food panel would be the array 10.
So there's different reasons why you run different labs.
Some are to find a what and get a better diagnosis to help you understand maybe why you have
certain symptoms.
Let's say you have, you know, joint pain all the time, I can't figure it out.
Well, if you knew you had arthritic antibodies or rheumatoid antibodies, it would give you
some clues to, okay, I got to get serious about, you know, fighting my triggers and dealing
with this because I could end up with, you know, remember, there's three different levels
of autoimmune disease, I'm going to end up in level 3 with tissue destruction, I have tissue
destruction because of rheumatoid antibodies, that's never going to heal, that's never going
to go away.
I have swan lake deformity of my fingers because of rheumatoid, you're never going to get
that back.
And when you, the more, you know, tissue damage you have, the less chance you have a recovery
of that tissue.
So all this information is on our autoimmune course if you want to dig deeper in that.
Our courses are only $50, we put a bunch of, a couple of months ago and we've had such
a response that we've just left them at that.
So for $50 to start learning some videos, watching some videos and learning some things about
autoimmune disease can be extremely helpful, highly suggest that.